I want you to close your eyes and think of a memory that makes you happy.
Now, think of a memory you associate with your youth.
Now consider the most painful memory of your life, now open your eyes.
This device extracts the actual memory from your brain and displays it before you
The machine...is incredible. Pure unfiltered truth.
This is a terrible loss.
I just wanted to say how truly sorry I am.
How did you know Gordon?
He saved my life.
He was found dead in his office with gunshots in the wall.
Gunshots.
No bullet wounds.
He was working with a lot of troubled people.
We need to find out what happened to you, Gordon. It's the least I could do.
They can't see your memories, but I could see the memories of those near you
Who are you?
I'm working for his widow. I know you saw him that night.
I Ioved him.
- Can I help you?
- Yes. Alison?
- Alison is Dead.
You think they're hiding something?
- There are people looking for you, if -
- A man has been murdered...got bigger things to worry about.
Word cannot get out about Gordon's death.
- What do you want from me?
- I want to ask you questions about Gordon --
- Get out!
The mind forgets things for a reason.
There are adverse affects to the machine -- time collapse, hallucinations
Do you know who this is?
Lawton has been lying.
I think I know who killed Gordon.
I would hate if I found out that you are lying.
You have something you wish you could forget.
Who are you?
Put it down. Put it down!
Help me!